>> LEFT-WING MEDIA IS PLAYING
QUARTERBACK WITH THE RESPONSE.
SOME CLAIMING THE GOVERNORS
EFFORTS FALL SHORT.
TO SANTOS IS STANDING BY HIS
DECISIONS AND PUSHED BACK AT ONE
CNN REPORTER WHO QUESTIONED HIS
CHOICES.
>> WHY DO YOU STAND BEHIND
LEE COUNTY'S DECISION TO NOT
HAVE THE MANDATORY EVACUATION
UNTIL THE DAY BEFORE THE STORM?
>> WHERE WAS YOUR INDUSTRY
STATIONED WHEN THE STORM HIT?
WERE YOU IN LEE COUNTY?
NO, YOU WERE IN TAMPA.
THEY WERE FOLLOWING THE WEATHER
TRUCK AND HAD TO MAKE DECISIONS
BASED ON THAT.
>> KAYLEE, JUST DESTROYING THE
REPORTER WITH FACTS AND FIGURES.
>> Kayleigh: WITH FACT YOU
CAN'T DENY.
AS A LIFELONG FLORIDIAN I LIVED
THROUGH STORMS YOU SEEN THEM
CHANGE, CHARLIE PRINCETON'S WAS
SUPPOSED TO HIT TAMPA BAY HOURS
BEFORE, SHIFTS TO HIT CHARLOTTE.
YET TO BALANCE FACTORS, MASS
EVACUATIONS CAN CAUSE MASS
PROBLEMS AND HEADACHES WHICH WE
SELL WITH HURRICANE RITA WITH A
2.5 MILLION PERSON TRAFFIC JAM,
YOU CAN'T JUST EVACUATE THE
ENTIRE STATE.
NUMBER THREE AND QUICKLY THE
GOVERNOR SEEMED PUT TOGETHER
WITH A FIVE MINUTE VIDEO ON HIS
RUMBLE ACCOUNT OF ALL THE TIMES
HE SAID EVACUATE, STAY SAFE.
THE I CAN SHIFT HE SAID
SEPTEMBER 25TH, SEPTEMBER 26TH
FINALIZED OUR PREPARATION, WE
HAVE STEPPED ON MY OPEN
EVERYWHERE.
HE TALKED ABOUT SOUTHWEST
FLORIDA EVACUATED, LITERALLY
WATCH 5 MINUTES OF THIS.
MAGGIE HABERMAN, ENOUGH WITH THE
TWEET.
JOURNALISTS AND UP WITH THE
BLAME GAME THIS IS PURELY
POLITICS AS THEY TRY TO DOWN
SOMEONE TOUTED AS A PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE AND THAT IS SAD AND
SICK TO PLAY POLITICS ON THE
BACKS OF HURRICANE VICTIMS.
THAT IS WHAT IS HAPPENING, GO
WATCH THE FIVE MINUTE VIDEO.
>> AND LISA WADE IN AS WELL.
>> I'M SURE SHE DID, EMILY.
>> CHECK IT OUT.
>> ISN'T IT SOCIALISM WHEN THE
GOVERNMENT HELPS TO?
THIS IS THE QUOTE FROM
GOVERNOR DeSANTIS ABOUT
CLIMATE CHANGE.
"I AM NOT IN THE PEWS OF THE
CHURCH OF THE GLOBAL WARMING
LEFTISTS."
THIS IS WHAT HE DIGS ABOUT
CLIMATE CHANGE AND NOW HIS STATE
IS GETTING HIT WITH ONE OF THE
WORST HURRICANES.
>> IT'S NOT EVEN LEADERSHIP, HE
ALL HE HAS TO DO IS OPEN HIS
ARMS AND RECEIVED FEDERAL MONEY.
LET'S BE CLEAR.
THAT ITS EXECUTIVE LEADERSHIP.
HE HAS TO GO HAT IN HAND TO
JOE BIDEN FOR AID.
IT IS SOMETHING HE DIDN'T EVEN
BELIEVE IN AS A TEA PARTY OR.
>> WHAT IS SHE TALKING ABOUT?
[LAUGHTER]
I CAN'T.
>> SHOULD I PULL MY HAIR OUT NOW
OR LATER?
FOR JOY BEHAR, THERE IS A
CATEGORY THREE IN FLORIDA IN
1851 SO YOU MIGHT WANT TO
RETRACT YOUR IDIOTIC STATEMENT.
LOOK, WHAT THIS SHOWS TO ME AS
THERE IS NOTHING ELSE TO ATTACK
GOVERNOR DeSANTIS ON BESIDE
THE FACT IS NOT A FORTUNE
TELLER.
AS WAS POINTED OUT EVERYONE WAS
FOLLOWING THE MODELS AND THEY
THOUGHT TEMPLE MIGHT BE IN WORSE
HIT SO THAT'S WHERE THEY WERE
LOCATED.
WHAT PEOPLE FORGET IS IT IS UP
TO LOCAL OFFICIALS TO GIVE OUT,
THEY ARE THE ONES THAT ARE
SUPPOSED TO GIVE US WARNINGS
FROM THE EVACUATION WARNINGS.
SECONDLY GOVERNOR DeSANTIS
MENTIONED AT LEAST SEVEN TIMES
IN THREE DAYS PRIOR TO LANDFALL
WARNING PEOPLE ON THE GULF COAST
TELLING THEM TO HEAT EVACUATION
ORDERS WE DON'T HAVE POLICE
GOING AROUND DOOR TO DOOR
PULLING PEOPLE OUT OF THE HOMES,
IT'S UP TO YOU TO DECIDE.
THANKFULLY WHAT WE HAD WITH THE
DeSANTIS ADMINISTRATION IS
EVEN BEFORE AND AFTER JUST A
WELL EXECUTED MACHINE OF GETTING
OUT LIKE WE NEED TO DO TO SAVE
PEOPLE IN THE PROCESS OF SAVING
LIVES AND SINCE I HAVE BECOME A
FLORIDIAN I GOT TO KNOW
GOVERNOR DeSANTIS WELL AND HIS
TEAM AS WELL.
HE IS ONE OF THE MOST COMPETENT
PEOPLE I HAVE EVER MET IN MY
ENTIRE LIFE NOT JUST FOR A
POLITICIAN, PERIOD.
HE IS BRILLIANT, ORGANIZED,
SPEAKS FOR HIS TEAM AS WELL.
WE AS FLORIDIANS COULD NOT BE IN
BETTER HANDS THAN WITH
GOVERNOR DeSANTIS AND WE HAVE
ALREADY SEEN THAT.
THE ONLY THING THEY CAN ATTACK
HIM ON HE IS NOT A FORTUNE
TELLER?
THAT IS THE ATTACK?
HE IS SUPPOSED TO BE ABLE TO
PREDICT THIS WHEN NOBODY ELSE TO
DO?
SPARE ME.
EVEN THAT, RECEIVING FEDERAL AID
FOR YOUR CITIZENS THAT IS SUCH A
MISNOMER TO CALL THAT AN ISSUE
OF FEDERALISM AND THAT A TEA
PARTY WOULD'VE BEEN AGAINST IT
BECAUSE IT MISSES THE ENTIRE
POINT.
ONE FOCUS IS ON AUTHORITY AND
AUTONOMY AND SOVEREIGNTY AND THE
OTHER IS THAT FEMA IS NOT A
FEDERAL ORGANIZATION AND ALL
AMERICANS WILL BE THE RECIPIENTS
OF FEDERAL AID IN THESE TIMES OF
NATURAL DISASTERS.
WHAT IS INTERESTING JUST BEFORE
THE SHOW I WAS TALKING TO LISA
IN THE GREEN ROOM AND THERE WAS
ALSO SOMEONE ELSE THERE WAS
RIGHT AFTER YOU LEFT WHO FELT A
DIFFERENT WAY ABOUT THE GOVERNOR
POLITICALLY.
HE SAID REGARDLESS HOW I FEEL
ABOUT HIM, HE LIVES IN FLORIDA,
HIS RESPONSE WAS EXCELLENT.
UNDENIABLE EXCELLENCE.
HOWEVER WE HAVE THIS MEDIA THAT
INSISTS ON RIPPING HIM APART
WHEN ALL FLORIDIANS ARE GRATEFUL
FOR EVERYTHING HE DID UNDER THE
EMERGENT SITUATION.
>> Harris: UNFORTUNATELY I
DIDN'T SEE THE DATELINE ON THAT
SO I DON'T KNOW IF THAT HAPPENED
BEFORE OR AFTER KAMALA HARRIS'
COMMENTS BUT I WOULD SAY THIS,
YOU CAN'T HAVE IT BOTH WAYS.
YOU CAN'T SAY ONLY PEOPLE IN
DIVERSE LANES GET THE AID AND
THEN OH, BY THE WAY, IF YOU ARE
ASKING FOR AID, YOU ARE
FEDERALLY CONSTIPATED.
YOU SHOULDN'T GET ANYTHING
BECAUSE YOU DON'T DESERVE IT
BECAUSE YOU WERE A MEMBER OF THE
TEA PARTY BARRIER WHICH IS IT
GOING TO BE?
>> David: HOW DOES THAT FIGURE
INTO IT?
FACT FOR JOEY READ, JOYCE
SQUARED WHATEVER, THERE'VE BEEN
SIX MAJOR STORMS IN THE LAST 50
YEARS, BEFORE THAT THERE WERE 16
SO CAN WE THROW CLIMATE CHANGE
OUT OF THE WINDOW NOW I GET BACK
TO FACTS?
>> Harris: CAN I SAY ONE MORE
THING ABOUT GOVERNOR DeSANTIS
QUICKLY?
AT ONE POINT DAYS AGO BEFORE
LANDFALL I THOUGHT HE DID A
REALLY COPIOUS JOB, I MEAN IT
WAS DETAILED, IF YOU THINK YOU
CAN'T LEAVE I CAN HELP YOU FIND
A PLACE TO GO BASED ON WHAT YOUR
OPTIONS ARE.
IT MAY NOT BE A SHELTER, MAYBE
IT IS SOMEPLACE A FRIEND LIVES,
YOU DON'T HAVE TO GO 200 MILES
AWAY TO GET AWAY FROM LANDFALL.
HE WAS JUST TRYING TO GET PEOPLE
TO JUST GET MOVING.
JUST GO SOMEPLACE WITH SOMEBODY
WHO MIGHT EVEN BE CLOSER IN THEM
IN ORLANDO.
AS IT TURNS OUT HE HAD TO
FURTHER THAT MESSAGE A DAY LATER
WITH YOU KNOW WHAT?
NO MATTER WHERE YOU ARE, YOU MAY
NOT BE ORDERED TO EVACUATE BUT I
NEED FOR YOU TO STAY IN YOUR
HOUSE IS.
>> LEE COUNTY EVEN HAD
EVACUATION ORDERS ARE BELIEVED
24 HOURS BEFORE.
THEY TRY TO GET THE WORD OUT, WE
DO THE BEST WE CAN IN THESE
SITUATIONS.
>> TO YOUR POINT HE DIDN'T
EXCELLENT JOB BECAUSE NOW ALL
THE CRITICISM IS FOCUSED TOTALLY
ON IRRELEVANT THINGS L